you are a national speech champion yes
is it speech and debate or just speech
speech and debate speech and debate but
I didn't do the debate part okay okay
but what I want to say is that you yeah
that's fine
you are you're kind of a legend in that
world you would just have some success
people in that world really know of you
and you won't really do so I I did I won
the National speech tournament three
times humorous interpretation dramatic
interpretation original oratory and and
that the name for it is forensics they
call it forensics but it's not the like
I chopped up dead people and investigate
criminal activity forensics its Speech
and Debate so people will come up to me
on the street and they'll stop me to
this day and I guess they watch my video
tapes of my my competitions right and
they'll stop me and they'll say oh my
god i watch your forensics tapes and to
a layman that sounds crazy right that
sounds clinic I know that you're into
dissecting dead people yeah sorry so
like a bunch of people out there hear
that conversation and are like I didn't
know Josh was into them but you are but
I am and you enjoy it I do do you still
do I mean first of all did you get do
you get a trophy when you win you get
truck you got trophies I did I love how
you acted like oh that's just the
beginning uh and that's all
and also money yeah I'm gonna get money
right not yeah yep crap you like money
day apparently really like yeah I really
think trophies